a type 1a supernova is thought to be a
white dwarf that undergoes total
thermonuclear detonation it explodes and
completely obliterates itself leaving no
remnant for example we have yet to get
to detect a neutron star or a black hole
remnant of a type on a supernova
explosion it appears that the stellar
explosion completely destroys the star
this explosion is extremely energetic
the amount of energy released is
approximately 10 to the 51 10 to the 52
of energy in other words a type 1a
supernova can outshine the galaxy it's
in the entire galaxy for for a short
time and so they are extremely energetic
t pick siddhis is a
current Nova not a supernova but a
classical Nova but it recurs most
classical Novi we've seen only once T
Pyxis has a classical Nova explosion
every roughly 20 years and this
continued from the early 1890s until
1967 so there were there were five Nova
explosions interspersed every every
roughly 20 years up until night up until
the 1967 explosion since nineteen sixty
seven this 20 year cycle has disappeared
nothing has happened yet in other words
it's 44 years overdue for the next
thermonuclear explosion what happens in
a recurrent nova and the reason i
distinguish it from supernova is that a
recurrent nova is a white dwarf this is
a star about the size of Earth and but
it has an extremely high density the
density is a hundred million grams in a
cubic centimeter force up for them for a
massive white dwarf hundred million
grams is cubic centimeter which means a
thimbleful of this material would be
hundreds of tons if you waited here on
earth the what happens is the white
dwarf is so dense that the electrons
surrounding nuclei have all been
stripped away from the nuclei and the
electrons are actually forced to form a
separate gas we call it a generate
electron gas what happens is when you
squeeze matter tighter and tighter
there's a principle in physics called
the Pauli exclusion principle it states
that no more than two electrons with
opposite spins can occupy the same
energy state so what happens is when you
squeeze matter tighter and tighter to
higher and higher density there are
fewer and fewer energy states available
to the electrons to occupy because all
the lowest-lying energy states are
filled first so an electron is forced to
move very very fast and it can't it
can't slow down it can't be excite
because the Pauli principle prevents it
there and so what happens is these
electrons move extremely fast and as the
density goes up the faster they move
faster and faster and that exerts
pressure well it's the pressure of these
de general electrons the degenerate
electron gas that
opposed that that prevents gravity from
pulling the stuff in but it's but but
what happens is that as the as the white
dwarf mass increases there's an ultimate
mass limit called the Chandrasekhar
limit beyond which a white dwarf cannot
exist because that the chantress a car
limit the degenerate electron gas
pressure can no longer withstand the
pull of gravity it can no longer
balanced gravity and prevent the
collapse of the white dwarf type 1a
supernovae occur very close to the
Chandrasekhar limit when the white dwarf
mass is very close to San Jose take our
limit t pyx Ennis has a white dwarf
which is very close to the Chandrasekhar
limit it's presently determined mass
fairly reliably well determined is 1.37
solar masses the Chandrasekhar limit for
a carbon-oxygen white dwarf is 1.4 for
solar masses so it doesn't have much
more material to accumulate until it
reaches the chanters safe our limit in
which case you'd have instantaneous
collapse but just before that happens as
as the white dwarf grows at mass the
compressional heating the weight of the
material from the neighboring star from
its companion presses down and raises
the temperature high enough to detonate
carbon that is to cause the carbon
nuclei inside the white dwarf to fuse
together releasing energy and so that
that is what we call a a detonation and
that's the team pick siddhis we believe
is very close to that point where the
little bit more mass accreted onto the
white dwarf will lead to so so much
heating that the temperature will rise
to a few billion degrees detonating
carbon but the carbon wanted when it
when it ignites fuel infusion ignites
its explosive because this this weird
gas that is the general electron gas
unlike an ideal gas like the Sun is made
over the air we breathe where you heat
it and expands the degenerate electron
gas has no sensitivity to temperature so
it doesn't know it's being heated in
other words the heat builds up the
nuclear
reactions occur faster and faster and
faster but there's no compensating
expansion to cool off and so it's like a
time bomb energy builds up very rapidly
and you get a tremendous thermonuclear
explosion that's a type 1a supernova
that that is a class a classical nova
takes place when the hotly accreted
hydrogen burns but it burns in a generat
region and you get a classical nova
explosion that's about 10 to the 45 ergs
of energy it's it's it's a million times
less energetic than a supernova the
supernova I'm talking about is is the
carbon nuclei not the hydrogen created
hydrogen with the carbon nuclei detonate
a fuse together and that's the type 1a
supernova that that will happen if he
picks it is when it reaches its close to
the Chandrasekhar limit
at the present rate of accretion that
our modeling indicates 40 pics Attis it
will take another ten million years
roughly 10 million years to reach 1.44
solar masses if the present mass of the
white dwarf is 1.37 solar masses and if
the accretion rate that we've estimated
from our accretion disk model fitting
from theoretical models of accretion
distance there's a pancake of matter
surrounding the white dwarf a pancake
shaped disk of gas we call an accretion
disk and that accretion disk is is
adding material to the white dwarf but
at the rate at which is adding material
of the white dwarf it's going to be
another ten million years roughly before
the Chandrasekhar limit is reached
as the as the interior the core the
white dwarf becomes hotter and hotter do
the compression and the temperature gets
up into a few billion degrees the
ignition temperature of carbon will be
reached that is carbon will be able to
undergo carbon on carbon fusion with the
release of energy this will start out
according to supernova models there have
been carried out in the last few years
this this will start out as what we call
a deflagration the the burning front
will propagate will move will move
outward at subsonic speeds but as as
this burning front moves out eventually
it very soon it will turn into a
supersonic a burning front you'll have a
breakout of the shock wave or blast wave
from this thermonuclear explosion that
breakout will should will produce a
burst of gamma rays and hard x rays very
high-energy radiation for a few seconds
this this radiation if the supernova is
close enough this radiation could then
affect earth in other words you would
have input of hard x-rays and gamma rays
into our atmosphere this could introduce
chemical reactions producing a lot of
nitrous oxide which could could then it
eventually destroy the ozone layer I
mean that that's that's the first thing
you think about is that if the ozone
layer is destroyed then you know the
very high energy radiation is lethal to
DNA we destroy the biosphere but the the
supernova has to be close enough now
type 1a supernovae are you know that
they're there they're more common that
then type to the type to super know when
the ordinary person thinks of a type 2
supernova when the public thinks of a of
a normal supernova think of a huge
massive star that collapses in on itself
produces a black hole or a pulsar at the
center and then this high-velocity
expanding gas that type of supernova
called a type 2 supernova comes from
very massive stars the
that are very luminous before they went
supernova there they can be seen at
great great distances what makes a type
1a supernova really unusual in that
regard is that the a white dwarf is very
dim and even white dwarfs and close
binaries or mass transfer is going on
they're really very faint you don't see
them out to very long distances and
there and they're more common type of
star and therefore since there are more
common and fainter they really pose some
reason to be concerned because you don't
see them as easily as as more massive
stars that are much more luminous so I
think the the main thing that one might
be concerned about is the input of
high-energy radiation into our
atmosphere but the supernova if you go
on the basis of tight to supernovae then
the current estimates are that if the
type to supernova is within roughly 30
30 light-years 30 30 or 40 light-years
or closer then you'd really have massive
input of high-energy radiation but
that's for type 2 supernovae and
collaborator dr. Packard go dawn at
Villanova I just did a quick back of the
envelope calculation and determined that
if if you had within a thousand parsecs
a type 1a supernovae go off and if it
was a low till such at the accretion
disk and and material didn't didn't
block the break out of it of the blast
way you would have a burst of gamma rays
that would essentially be as bright as
the Sun and the the the estimate by
Peter huh flick is that 10 to the forty
eight to ten to the 50 herbs per second
of in hard x-rays and gamma rays would
be emitted so and we don't know exactly
how far away we know that it's closer
than thousand parsecs but how much
closer our best estimates right now or
it could be the models allow it to be as
even as close as five hundred parsecs
but that may be too far for it to do
real damage to earth but we're still
we're still working on this and we're
submitting a paper to the asked physical
journal letters on this topic